there were tragedies almost every hour
of every day
not just the documented ones the
tragedies of people climbing on planes
but the little tragedies of people with
documents not getting admitted or
families getting separated and what some
people being admitted and others not but
if you had young family members if you
weren't in a position where you could
wait for days or push through that crowd
or you were being given conflicting
instructions those you know that middle
checkpoint of just the humanity to get
through and then the actual um you know
verification stage at the gates became
very challenging to reach planes took
off with empty seats repeatedly
so it's not the case that it was like oh
we're turning you away because there
isn't enough space that was not what was
going on what was going on was the
typical chaos
of a bureaucracy under the strain of
immense crisis the states being made by
by good meaning people but operating
under very tough circumstances with the
fall of kabul on august 15th it just
turned into a massive you know hysteria
over there people trying to get out
names were
getting added to lists but then the
lists weren't getting updated quickly
enough or
people at checkpoints who hadn't slept
well in days couldn't read
you know the names properly or read the
first name as the last name there were
random uh people getting through that
that were cleared not cleared and that
others who were cleared could not get
through it was it was just chaos the
taliban trying to disperse individuals
there were people who got crushed to
death in that crowd folks who were
collapsing because of heat dehydration
it was an incredibly dangerous and
chaotic scenario that's just the people
who made it to kabul i mean think about
all the people all across the country
who
never even got
to kabul let alone to the airport i mean
it a lot of people
got stuck
because of
the speed with which the collapse
occurred
while many people predicted the collapse
imminent collapse i think the speed took
almost everybody even perhaps the
taliban itself
by surprise without a plan the u.s
government did not have a plan going
into this
uh that it just turned into this
haphazard uh some got in some didn't and
we all saw the images on television but
i think that just points directly back
to the commander-in-chief
the lack of leadership the lack of a
game plan not listening to top brass i
mean millie himself said that he had
urged the president to do this a
different way
it was backwards we started taking our
you know forces out we started moving
away from protecting americans and our
allies before we really had a plan in
action the bagram air force or air base
that the military us military air base
should have been kept open that would
have been the easiest way to evacuate
the citizens or and american citizens as
well as allies we were told early on
before the evacuation started that they
had looked at every scenario possible
well they didn't they clearly didn't
because if they had of we would not have
13 gold star families for no reason
whatsoever we could have saved the lives
of the marines that were lost in
afghanistan lately
we just didn't need to go down that road
but i believe it's because no one knows
what's happening no one understood how
many americans were there no one had a
game plan and again we have never been
given straight answers there was also
some ambivalence in the by
administration well we're going to have
time we don't have to throw a bunch of
people just because the afghan
government's gonna hold we're gonna be
able to process these at embassies at
the same time do we really want
everybody leaving that we've trained up
to we need people to run the government
deliver services and fight the war do we
really want all these people bugging out
and so that was that was some of the
assumptions that went into this so uh
it's just it's huge effort that's it
needs to ramp up and continue because
really it's
it's not over i mean the the sometimes
you hear about oh the evacuation it's
complete or it's no it's not it's very
much not complete there's still hundreds
of thousands of people over there still
president biden didn't start the war but
it's really how that's how it's ending
is the
key right now is
we're not doing a good job of of ending
it the way this evacuation is taking
place